I'll see how this goes hopefully it's a
nail-biter I would much rather be
chasing people than trying to be chased
I do not like having to watch over my
back I want to chase somebody down on a
nail-biter are we gonna have that we
will see ok another quick run down what
do we got now 70 players average rating
1779 time is the handicap ending in 30
minutes
criteria nothing no level requirement
5 4 3 game tournament on and it's ok to
double those points I will not be
clicking on that resign button those of
you that have had a last video I think
that one was ok here we go
double those points you can get this
thing out of here get that thing out of
my window please
oh it's the wild wing gambit ok
let's strike in the center get my bishop
out and hopefully I don't come under
heavy fire okay give me the H file to
play with please please just give me
that ok they're ready to UM gain some
space and now I'm gonna fix that pun on
a dark square and if the Queen gives
check I just block and I defend
everything let's go here let's just go
here and I'm that Queen again I could
still do this move could still do it
okay I'm okay with my King coming out
I'm alright with that I'm on c2 are they
gonna miss it
come on fall for it oh-oh let's come
here because I want my rook on C and if
pawn push I could do this oh let's come
over here my Knights defended by my
bishop I want my Knight here or even
maybe even here what's my rib do and I
probably should have played here okay
let's do this it's come back scarred
that guy whoa
how much time do I have okay
time this night has to go I can't work
with that night being there I don't want
to keep my night does not too excited
about hanging out on h6 for any amount
of time so let's get it back involved in
the center here we go
pinpointing these squares get in there
get in there ninety-four hitting
everything g3 okay my opponents stopping
that let's get to see for now that's
weakened as well are they gonna move
their night they're not they're not
gonna move their night so incoming I'm
gonna with my rook on aged to c8 not now
though because that was hanging and
they're down a time so I'm gonna doing
nothing moving back to tournament to to
to a bunch of two's a bunch of two's
venko gamba tier the Benko gamba tear
okay here we go build a center kill the
dark square Bishop let's no let's not do
that
let's do d5 Queen d2 Bishop h6 Bishop h6
whoa would change in the structure okay
I have the opportunity to take out for
Sun but clearly I didn't do that 93
let's do that before it's maybe too late
I want to stop knight h5 that's the main
idea I did not declare my king position
your stand I guess b5 could be coming in
at any second let's do this let's do
this let's do this right away Knight F
to G for I think everything is under
control if the knight moves my opponents
dead if that Knight moves I think
they're dead okay and the Queen side is
closed usually that's maybe a drawback
okay let's chop that before it's too
late the the bishop might have tucked
itself back on h8 let's give a check and
hope for the best here let's hope for
the best on g5 and then e 6 hope for the
best is the plan I actually just here
filed by um well I don't want to lose my
clean is that me
it is me okay I was hitting h7 and our
last position so we got a bunch of our
no not a bunch of six six five four and
are they not going to pair me up this
happens quite a bit when I get paired up
from
with someone from India okay that is
actually relatively quick I usually have
to wait an eternity um are they gonna
move oh no you know how I feel about non
movers you know how I feel about non
movers and we have a non over so what do
you do when there's a non mover you um
you root for somebody who's in the lead
are not in the lead to beat somebody
that is like right here like this guy so
what's going on with this game
this guy is tied with me so far let me
take a quick peek at my game no still
nothing exciting happening still nothing
exciting happening in my game in this
game come on white let's go white get
out of this hurry up before there's a
pin d3 and then getting f4 right
still no moving nothing going on in that
in this game here 14 13 who's gonna win
this White's looking pretty good come on
white all right I got a cut out three
two one back to this one here back to
tournament Oh 12 who has 12 Elliot chess
I am gonna hunt you down I am gonna hunt
you down I'm gonna try to at least
hunting you down oh here we go here we
go
who's this here we go um both just move
okay
the Slavs the Slav the Slav the Slav
okay let's try them the it's like a
Dutch isn't it isn't this like a Dutch
now Stonewall Dutch okay
let's give it a whirl let's give it a
whirl here uh-oh uh-oh no tension in the
center no pressure on this square means
what what does that mean
looking for me come on you know you want
to miss it
yes you did want to miss it back to
tournament 17 12 12 11 10 what I was
saying that c5 push released the tension
in the center and allowed me to expand
with E 5 without them any drawback okay
so now actually this could be a
liability liability city right here c7
let's take like this I'm not sure why I
like this grip in the center okay and
how things are smooth and maybe I could
work with this and take that pond
they're giving me it I'm not going to
though I'm fearing something that I just
can't quite explain just yet so Castle
queenside king b1 I don't want to get
into it like a little rat race type of
oh that we can this square let's let's
pile up on this hit the Queen Czech
Queen trade hit this second time got
these bishops they're mean-looking
they're mean-looking here pin the night
now that's back on okay let's put
pressure on this guy what does my queen
think she's doing um okay let's trade
let's come on this light square diagonal
this is where I want to be this is right
where I want to be this is right where I
want to be I think I think this is where
I want to be oh is this where I want to
be what about here let's try it let's
just try it and hope for the best
no that's not quite working aha man this
isn't this I'm down a lot of time here
I'm down a lot of time I want to watch
out for a night there and then we're
gonna have a queen trade okay we are
aren't we okay let's move quickly here
let's move quickly come on move quickly
okay King up no we're gonna have that
trade okay I guess so oh oh
Supreme of pre-move time they're gonna
give a check I'm gonna go back I'm in a
worse position okay me lay my booby
they're gonna come back no they're not
oh I'm in trouble the rook is going
crazy on my pawns right here oh oh why
did I do that
come over here I gotta throw in some
checks here hang on let's back up
let's come back here are they gonna take
my pond let's come back and then I'm
gonna sneak in and a pond I'm gonna
launch an 8 pound attack I trick them
come back here let's do this and tuck my
King in a little corner here and my poem
is flying why are they flying ok I gotta
fly to UM check oh come on over here
check over here check oh oh they're
throwing checks Oh hoo hoo one eye 1.60
2720 20/20 I should not have won that
one the quicker Mouse the quicker Mouse
got that one
let's close out of that a lot of time
left
Wow 21 the big bad wolf
is this a wolf I forget they want to
draw I don't want to drop the ha ha
back to tournament back to tournament
the quick resigner
king rook 2012 2012 King rook
mm 2012 all right we have been here
before we have been here before haven't
we and this is um I played this already
in the stream where the this bishop is
not he's not too happy he's not too
happy about how things have just played
out here he's kind of stuck isn't he
he's stuck behind a wall of his own puns
I can't be helping so night here okay
now dark square weaknesses let's come to
c5 that's the newly weakened square as a
result of my opponents last move so
let's get to it
hop to at night I'm gonna take away from
the center I would like to get on this
square and now actually they just
dropped their night and I better not
drop my queen and that's what they're
ready to do but I'm ready to drop my
bishop so let's go here and my bishop
wants to come to e1 let's come to you
one everything's gonna be nice and cosy
once you're on c3
I'll allow that pond to be exchanged I
will allow that to happen and let's get
a clean exchange okay clean exchange
how're we doing timewise how are we
doing timewise hopefully it's okay get
my king over okay now that's number one
priority get this pond and then
everything is quite all right let's
trade a little bit and there we go now
my bishop will not be will not be what
come on let's go weasel around this is
the diagonal you know you want to be on
let's get there push push push push
you got to take now I think okay what do
we got just watch out for sneaky pawn
moves let's come all the way back come
here and my bishops are guarding they're
paving the way for the rest of hang on
hang on it's not steel mate okay it's
still not stalemate and just in case
let's do that just so it's not stalemate
ever just so it's not stalemate ever I
always have that pond takes
okay back to tournament land 4742 the
king of pirates the king of pirates is
right here on my heels who is the king
of pirates okay
No let's get that in before it's too
late
oh I thought for a second I can maybe
clamp down okay let's get rid of the
LightSquared Bishop let's give a check
see how they want to deal with that do
they want to deal with that at all okay
no no no no now I want my knight here
I'm gonna take that night if there's a
question put to it let's I don't want to
deal with the knight sitting there let's
get here let's get here and then let's
get out of anything crazy anything crazy
like a knight move and then my queen is
dead oh I almost missed my queen would
have been dead right there I don't want
to have to deal with dead Queens ecigs
let's come here I'm on the bishop bishop
here could be good or a five
85 even better maybe oh not here oh look
here that's how I have to defend okay
I'm in trouble
I am in a position cultural okay let's
get my king up let's defend here I have
lateral defence Oh pancakes no let's
keep these guys disjointed disjointed
let's get that the rook is dead isn't it
it's a dead rook dead rook got the
bishop got the pawn my bishops watching
over a let's chop that guy and come up
to the rescue King come to the rescue
I got that bishop what am I missing
Oh
let's give check I'm fearful of this
rook thing Oh
oh man is this helpful oh this is
working just in the nick of time how did
that happen how did that happen let's
give a check just for fun right there
just a burn time hit the rook and okay
now let's win this one let's win this
one quick it's open stuff up let's take
it stake again let's give check okay
back back back back to tournament 63 56
56 any of those two guys can catch me oh
come on let's maybe pull ahead here pull
ahead okay launch an H pawn attack each
pawn attack let's get that night out of
there before E 5 comes ok get that dark
square Bishop are they gonna give me it
if the position opens up the King could
be subjected to problems on this
diagonal don't tell me I didn't warn you
this diagonal dark swear diagonal bad
things bad things can happen fast
telling you I'm trying to tell you here
hmm hang on let's try this
maybe that Knight will give itself up
oh we're gonna see about that okay I am
in some trouble Queen takes mate threat
let's not miss mate threats I would get
really really loud if that happened so
beware beware okay
beware of my time right here my time is
what I need to be aware of forget about
this diagonal I don't have a piece
around that could give check anymore oh
man I need f4 and play I could give a
check I can keep that night around
hopefully they end up in a fork
come on fourth is the rook dad is the
knight dead is some piece dead oh the
rook is dead let's chop this next rook
trade rook trade come on go rook go rook
let's chop that come over here they're
gonna stop me no are they gonna stop me
let's come over here to defend some
stuff oh that's a past pun I'm gonna go
with that
let's come over here for just a second
and here I'm looking for sneaky moves
let's just take this guy my pawn is fast
I gotta watch out for this slick move
they might be sneaky they still might be
sneaky they're not being sneaky okay
push push push push again check check
check
come on we've got a little ring around
the rosy thing going on here that's me
okay back to tournament 81 72-63 okay
king of pirates is lurking
he's a lurker this pirate the king of
pirates come on pair me up pair me up
currently 91 players 91 players I don't
know what the average rating is at this
point okay maybe that could turn into a
time loss taking away from the center
not advancing the development by doing
this and I think I have a good game
already I think looking for Forks come
on you know you want to miss it oh I
gotta watch this pawn build my Center
what did they just give up they gave up
their light square bishop their light
squares are weakened
killer move killer move they missed it
I'm on the Queen and the rook move the
Queen I get the rook and what next let's
chase this up guy away a little bit and
let's open it up
let's open this up and I'm on f2 oh this
is brutal isn't it it's gotta be uh-oh
the queen is dead the queen is dead this
might be a quick a fast resigner uh-oh
oh oh okay everything's covered I'm on
the night it's back up here I could have
taken the bishop and I probably should
have 25 seconds more than enough more
than enough okay let's do this what are
they gonna do now Oh everything is hit
isn't it everything is close to being
hit let's go here rook takes I'll throw
a check in first oh well I'll just take
if they go there check where is the
quick mate can we just have a quick mate
soon check actually this was me I
probably should have done that
there we go vac determined 101 90 this
guy is not going away he is just he's
being a pest here right there at 91 I
was gonna just play e4 let's not drop
upon so fast alright let's not drop
pawns in the beginning of a chess game
lets me be five okay they're not going
on with that here we go
H pawns age pawns love to attack when
there's a fee and cut up or yeah what am
I trying to say sometimes you could turn
into a good thing especially Castle and
opposite sides let's do this and then oh
they're getting nervous they're having
to defend let's take that and
I'm having to do some defense as well
I'm gonna take with the pond does that
look ridiculous you know Oh what are
they doing
let's keep check I'm in a pin and if I
take the Queen oh I'll just nod just
castle oh there now let's come with the
other one what's that what is my record
II think it's doing nothing so I could
pre-move it it's with check I get still
pre move it alright that's gotta be a
good move
just hook here and let's back up my
bishop cuz my knight wants to play let's
do that and well I don't watch your back
ranks
I don't watch for the back rank here Oh
ooh what's this what is that move how
did this happen oh man
hang on oh I don't know what's going on
I'm in trouble oh man what do I think I
just did I just lost a piece run here oh
this is bad why did I could do that oh
it's me it's gotta be me I'm dead this
is gonna be checkmate run King run to
the corner and hide but how much time do
I have right here I might trying to
check Oh take my queen oh oh oh oh how
much time I don't have any time ah I
love back to tournament why did I let
that happen
ah they threw in sneaky moves and I
wasn't prepared for the sneaky moves
oh that's it each puns each pine moves
here we go here we go I am coming down
with a CH pun moves for the rest of the
tournament here we go let's kill this
Bishop kill him dead go ahead take my
pawn I'm coming right after you okay
hang on ah
dad's a killer okay okay okay
what did I get out of this look at this
yeah there goes that attack it's so much
for this attack right oh where did that
go where did that TAC go it went nowhere
it went to a place called nowhere
nowhere okay yeah yeah it's not
happening it's not happening is it it's
just not oh my goodness look at how fast
that pond is oh okay I'll take that I'll
definitely take that and I'll take this
I have a flight Square uh why did I have
to lose that one just tell me why did I
have to lose that one well I was just
trying to blunder my rook can you
believe this believe it believe it it
was bound to happen
it was just ready to happen I was ready
to blunder my rook let's get that out of
there come on here we go I could win
this I could win this - all I need
that's all you need in this position run
what an attack though right went right
to the endgame come on I could have a
temple gaining move check temple guy
push push come on I got to catch this
guy the pirate the wild pirate is in the
lead and this guy's not resigning just
me it is me back to tournament two
people are ahead
138 131 uh-oh I need some quick wins
okay
scotch gambit why'd I do that
no this is too dry could I actually
still pull it now I don't have the
prerequisites for an attack do i or do i
okay let's get this in where does my
Knight want to be where's one night want
to being can I get some Forks here
please I want some Forks
let's do this it's not happening it's
not happening is that we're gonna have a
bunch of exchanges watch out knife I'd
have four Knight to f4 okay and now now
now now no no no what Knight to e5
Knight to e5 let's make that happen
let's make that happen and I gotta watch
out for f2 and I'll watch for out for f2
rook f3 as well ah trades more trades
okay so much for the quick win so much
for that when you call click it's not
happening it's definitely not happening
okay let's stop that night from doing
anything and I am in a place called
trouble right now I'm losing material
I'm losing material and I have to hope
for the best hear that my mouse is gonna
be with me be with me Mouse be with me
on this one
come on King get more central break open
that pawn structure there we go
now give checks give timely checks like
this chase the rook away capture towards
the center oh man I got a retreat let's
stop that let's stop that lets get into
a checking position cuz that's all I
have here oh I'm not in a good spot I'm
not in a good spot let's come here oh
let's just smooth move right there let's
try this okay this is gonna come down to
a time scramble which is um happening
quite a bit here come on you know you're
fast enough if we have a rook trade here
we go my pawn is faster legs he squeezed
quick look at how quick he is let's give
some checks and let's chop this guy up
and give some more checks and I'll head
back to tournament 139 oh they're
pulling ahead 158 158 151 139 the king
of pirates in a slew of other ones here
oh that last killed me let's go let's go
move one and two and three
one two three combo okay oh okay I got
it I actually come back and so much for
that that hurt that hurt oh let's do
this are they really gonna take that pun
yeah let's do this let's see what
they're doing now this is very oh I'm on
their queen I'm on the rook I'm stopping
mate I'm on the night let's take this
I get the knight next I'm not allowing
Queen here no way let's take this and
then let's come here and stop this come
on this this should be quick resigned
right I'm the queen oh okay okay what do
I want to do what do I want to do here
uh-oh I'm in trouble the diagonal and
stuff
Oh Queen trade oh they missed that come
on resign you know this is lost just
resigned give me a chance to come back I
want a chance to come back here they're
not resigning they're not resigning here
take my rook so I could give me they're
not doing that
pig pig here and then here oh I can't do
that
oh oh I'm Mel slipped oh I'm gonna get
mated don't let me get mated they're
ready to make me I think no they weren't
block and then I give check block with
the Brooke what oh that's me back to
turn it back to turn it back to term at
159 178 oh this isn't happening I need a
bunch of people to lose a quick resigner
I need two quick wins here what a
setback that one game was okay here we
go
how the anti-age pond attack
that's what you call the anti-age pun
attack oh let's just do this and flush
that bishop away get out of there Bishop
and quick mate quick mate defend this
pawn man come on where's a quick mate
when you need it here let's just open
stuff up
take that let's come here ah man I
getting made it or something am i
getting mated it's just not happening
these games have to end much much sooner
than they are and it's just not
happening there's night takes here maybe
night here coming up probably good okay
hopefully this works I'm on the Queen
they could be resigning quick come on
resign Knight takes Bishop keeps them in
the game sort of okay I'm just gonna do
that even if it's wrong even if it's
wrong I'm doing it I need to just burn
their clock I cannot let my clock tick
any more I'm gonna do that one as well
but I might be getting made it no no no
no no let's do this uh-oh now I might be
getting mated let's throw these in throw
them in burn the time back to tournament
179 are you kidding me 218 208 I had no
chance it I had no chance ever since I
lost that game ah I need like seven wins
here and I'm struggling to just get one
quick one they'll never suspect that
they did suspect it they did suspect
that one here we go let's chop that guy
up push this guy around
shop it there look okay okay
could we get something quick here um I'm
on the rook good for me come on come on
come on come on come on come on
this that's me that's me back to
tournament 199 11 seconds quick resigner
quick resigner seven six five four come
on pair me up and resign you know you
want to no hope come on resign double
the points just resigned come on are
they letting this play this one I'll get
mated oh man ah not happening fourth ah
let me close out ah
man good games who was the guy to beat
me ah I had no chance you lose one game
and that's it I guess ah that's true I
did want to chase people I did get my
wish but I wished for more I wished that
I wouldn't have lost games when I was
doing the chasing was this the guy that
beat me they're saying that they beat me
yeah looks familiar
ah they throw in the rook check and I
couldn't I was I need a better Mouse I'm
blaming on my mouse